[Music]
you know if you look at great works of
literature I always thought about how in
literature in art and culture there are
tools for living right and I think that
one of the tools for living that you
find in wonderful works of literature is
that human beings are complicated and
flawed human beings are not all one way
human beings are best understood in
their complexity and if only we had more
of that in our day-to-day I've been
thinking a lot about what it means to be
an excellent educator now that for the
first time in my you know really most of
my adult life I was a journalist for a
minute but I've been a teacher and now
that's not my job anymore so I've been
thinking about what are the
transferrable properties in what are the
ways that in our communities we think
about mentorship we think about
empowerment we think about sharing not
just to impose knowledge but rather to
share knowledge in a dynamic way that
again is about the self empowerment that
comes from knowledge from having an
expanded mind for having sharper tools
for being able to evaluate contradiction
and hold contradiction aloft sometimes I
think a good learning environment has to
have I think the tenets that brave
failure is preferable to a timid success
by which I mean I think our minds are
great and powerful things and I think
that to have courage inform our thinking
and to be able to go out perhaps past
where we may be comfortable to go into
the unknown between human beings and see
where that takes us to not stay safe in
our own position but to make it safe for
other people to be able to share I think
that that's where we get to new ideas
I think that's where we get to brave
ideas I think that's where we get to
solutions that we might not otherwise
have found so fostering an environment
that where people can be brave and where
ideas don't always have to be pristine I
think is is very important
[Music]